the incredible Victoria Falls one of the
natural wonders of the world is feeling
the strain we won't be passing African
you know to be made a new clothes you
know what we went extreme drought and
higher temperatures are taking its toll
on humans and animals and pitting them
against each other in the fight for
survival as the climates change
[Music]
the mighty Zambezi River is the
fourth-largest in Africa but when we
visited drought had reduced it in places
to its lowest in half a century
creating islands where once there were
none and threatening millions of
livelihoods reliant on this 1700 mile
water source
those are hippos in front there the
hippos
look at the tune some past years the
hippo they were not found like on the
meat of the river but now this year
because over the drought they are found
on the middle of the river and which is
not good sign
there are always seasonal variations and
in November the Zambezi is at its lowest
but even so those who've worked on this
river all their lives on noticing
changes goes up about 3 meters high from
this level where you see the water alone
yes dropped a lot and this is the lowest
month of the year
yeah October November
have you seen it this low before this is
the lowest it's been in about 25 years
apparently I'd say no this is the lowest
you've ever seen yes see the lowest and
that's had a dramatic effect in Zambia
and all who live along the river as well
as further afield Monteria gets paid but
I think of my mum who's at the village
oh they depend on farming
there is no range there's no enough food
for the kiddos yeah for the under they
keep so we are you scared yeah it's real
effect as much
we took to the air to get a different
view
[Music]
the zambezi feeds into one of the
natural wonders of the world
and a low river has impacted on the
Victoria Falls
[Applause]
well that isn't romantic site readable
changes
the president Azam BR agrees
Alex crew fitzco News thank you for
agreeing to talk to us sir in an
exclusive interview he blamed the
situation squarely on climate change
it's a serious problem a gentleman one
and he is surprised when people realize
it and say it's not true probably they
are living in a different world but this
world we live in Zambia we are feeling
the effects of climate change very
obviously and the impacting on everyone
everyone we are here as custodians and
that's trustees for the future so we
went to pass one with an edge without
big force want to pass on Africa to to
the Phillie direction without the mighty
weak force about what we want so there
are practices and divisions which we can
deliberately take now but how much
responsibility do you bear yourself and
know in your state of a nation address
you said that maybe mistakes had been
made did we do as a country prepare for
this adequately maybe not you said have
you not and I think maybe not the answer
we haven't done enough preparations as a
country and we are paying the price for
that but I think our hope is lost
well we know now the problem I can
address it and release some of the
effects and hopefully restore the
variability of
and it was CHP the drought has squeezed
everything making it a daily scramble to
find water and food for millions in
Zambia alone their livestock drink the
same water it's all they have Anna is a
mother of eight and a grandmother of 13
[Music]
if you want to okay
children's have many many yes because of
the bad water and the stomach water and
the search for it dominates their lives
I'm joining my dinner with you they're
struggling because that container of
water weighs 25 kilograms and I have to
carry the water to her home more than a
kilometer away several times a day what
we are going 6 things do containers for
both containers for drinking if you are
not watching 4 times Anna and millions
of other vulnerable families like hers
live from hand to mouth in Zambia anyway
changing climates makes it a daily fight
for survival it is still a magnificent
sight a visual feast
however depleted
there are a multitude of reasons why the
fools have been unusually low this year
the Zambia's huge dependency on
hydropower means waters being diverted
to provide electricity for a start but
many are convinced climate change is a
real and genuine danger I am incredibly
shocked 20 years ago 30 years ago we had
an estimation over 1,200 cubic meters
falling over the falls every second
within this period of a persistent
drought from 2018 to 2019 we've seen a
drastic reduction that's very scary and
that tells me that we're doing something
wrong as a country we're doing something
wrong as a region and perhaps we're
doing something wrong
globally and therefore this is a call to
action for us to do everything that we
must to reduce the global carbon
emissions through the minimum levels so
that we are able to restore the Earth's
natural ability to replenish itself
the tourist numbers have been affected
with hotel occupancy at only 40% in late
November and that hit pockets and bottom
lines
they're praying for a good rainy season
the world's longest curtain of flowing
water we'll be back in a few months but
what are the longer-term implications
[Music]
they're on the move hundreds of them in
search of food and water
elephants can spend up to 18 hours a day
grazing and drink up to 50 liters of
water in one session
so they're being hunted not to kill them
in this case but to help them live this
team from the World Wide Fund for Nature
in Zambia have been following the
elephants
after being darted and tranquilized
they're able to work with this giant
animal tomorrow they can weigh up to six
tons the team are fitting giant collars
to them each collar has a GPS tracking
device it means the elephant's can be
monitored and a log made of their habits
and which routes they take to get to
food and water this is important
information as influences land-use
planning where we're going to do
infrastructure where can we do
settlements and where we shouldn't do
anything and if it's done correctly it
will reduce human elephant or even
Wildlife complex in general and allow
for the free movement of Wildlife
between certain areas the elephants have
been wreaking terrible damage on the
environment in their quest to find food
the drought has forced them to look
elsewhere moving out of the bush
breaking out of the nature reserves and
into village communities they've
trampled over crops ruining livelihoods
as well as terrifying injuring and
killing residents this is a way of
trying to protect the animals and the
communities
but the whole operation comes with risks
yeah my ROI is basically from the
helicopter dot the elephant and wants us
down to make sure it's breathing and
stay alive once collared and all the
data collected the elephant's revived
they watch it from the helicopter until
it's fully recovered
the average adult elephant needs about
450 kilograms of food every day that's
an awful lot of food when extreme
weather has curtailed harvests and all
vegetation and their size makes them
especially destructive and frightening
usually processor we here mr. Simba is
the elephant troubleshooter around
Livingston he's the one they call when
elephants come prowling the mile after
mile of broken fences show their path
the fence is completely down here mr.
Simba patrols the area tracking the
elephant's down as they forage for food
his presence reassures the resident many
of these people are the poorest in
Zambia economically and nutritionally
vulnerable and most at risk very
dangerous for the human being
because we cannot stop them from moving
they some shop see along this line if
they want to buy something an effort
just to close it is the elephant to kill
someone just go here and what do the
elephants do how do they react with you
how they react to use the most
Dulli night time like this if you you
are crossing going somewhere it will
just come from the podcast it is done
like this you start guessing you chasing
you yeah so mr. zimberg
goes looking for them to make sure they
don't come too close or do too much
damage
Maru me the booty Joe kept on Gina
yes Yankees office nothing it's a
never-ending task right now
everyone here is desperate and there are
very slim pickings this is a problem for
the elephant trackers is that they moved
very quickly
they're very silent often at time but
they're causing a lot of terror in the
community they think they spot a small
group tonight his presence is keeping
the elephants at bay
yes last morning is before I think is
with zero three hours of skin this side
and the plenty tears are broken we face
in front entry is removing and their bus
is over here let's go listen is an
opening somewhere there and it's not
just elephants who are straying into
urban areas we came across this hippo on
one of Livingston's main roads there one
of the most dangerous animals in the
world highly aggressive and
unpredictable
you know look at that mug Lisa wall few
other regions are suffering from climate
change as much as southern Zambia pamela
does this 15 times a day gathering water
to feed seedlings in the hope she and
her six children will eventually be able
to eat the country's been gripped by
drought for four years now they
transport water huge distances whatever
way they can and families just being
kept at bay on the leds of way our
sisters used to live at least it was
cold rain season but now we don't know
where we are going and when we shall
receive
this used to be the Moranbah river but
most of its 100 kilometers had dried up
when we saw it leaving only tiny pools
behind and wildlife and humans fighting
over the small amounts crocodiles
they'll find they'll feel the pressure
as well a teenage girl was drawing water
here when she was set upon by a waiting
crocodile and there because it wasn't
very deep she managed to keep her head
above water and she fought this thing
for for a good 20 minutes before someone
came along and basically beat it over
that crocodile is now here being looked
after at a centre along with dozens of
others that have been rescued but
keeping them alive is a daily challenge
we're having to dig our pump down almost
on a daily basis just to try and follow
the water there's hardly any water there
it's only about 50 centimetres deep down
hmm so we have about 25 acres here and
it's very river rhine and lately we
found we found elephants being pressured
into crossing over our electric fence
they you know when they become really
desperate they just ignore the electric
fence this is elephant damage
and I basically caught the elephant
trying to strip the bark off and I came
and stopped it from treatment conflict
between humans and Wildlife is rising
and both are struggling to cope with
increasingly hostile and erratic climate
changes in climate can be catastrophic
for Zambia even slight temperature
differences spell disaster affecting
crops destroying lives and hitting the
poor hardest we suddenly Gordon every we
scream to make us survive the lack of
rain means animals have to scavenge
there are more and more clashes between
wildlife and humans with the low water
creating huge power problems and pitting
the economy it's facing in multiple
crises the lack of power has increased
charcoal burning forests have been
cleared for fuel the country's natural
resources are being lost at a terrifying
pace
and Zambia is paid the price perish the
staggering Victoria Falls is affected
and that has seen a drop in tourism one
of the stalwarts of the country's
economy
Zambia's treasures are shrinking amid
worries if no actions taken they could
disappear entirely eventually and
climate change is being blamed
[Music]